wer in tübingen etwas über politik
lernen will der muss mit boris palmer in
die obstbäume klettern
der mann kann stundenlang über die kunst
des richtigen zuschnitts von bäumen
sprechen als sohn eines obstbauern hatte
das von klein auf gelernt
dieses wissen gibt er gerne weiter hier
an studenten der uni tübingen und ganz
nebenbei gibt es eine einführung in die
politische farbenlehre wie in der
politik das schwarze ich alles schon
abgestorben und nur aus dem grünen
wächst noch was das wäre alles nicht
weiter erwähnenswert wenn der mann im
baum nicht mitglied der grünen wäre und
oberbürgermeister von tübingen und für
den ist der obstbaumschnitt eben mehr
als nur die kunst ein baum zu
beschneiden sondern eine politische
allegorie bin der meinung dass die
schichten die früher für grüne völlig
unerreichbar gewesen sind der klassische
ochs bauer hat immer schon cdu gewählt
dass die in baden württemberg auch ein
geheimnis des erfolgs sind dass wir
menschen erreichen die sich das früher
nicht hätten vorstellen können
seit sechs jahren wird tübingen grün
regiert dabei erscheint die stadt auf
den ersten blick sehr konservativ mit
80.000 einwohnern eher klein viel
schwäbische tradition und böse zungen
behaupten die engen verwinkelten gassen
seien auch ein bild für das konservative
weltbild der menschen hier tatsächlich
ist tübingen ein grüner mikrokosmos
30.000 studenten bevölkern die stadt
viele tübinger sind akademiker verdienen
ihr geld im öffentlichen dienst
klassisch grüne wählerschichten die hier
die mehrheit stellen und grüne politiker
die sehr selbstbewusst auftreten in
tübingen sind wir es gewohnt projekte so
anzugehen dass man sie auch umsetzen
kann
ich denke dass es in vielen anderen
orten nicht der fall und jetzt seit wir
in baden württemberg
regierungsverantwortung haben merken wir
durchaus dass ideen die wir an
voranbringen konzepte die wir
voranbringen auch tatsächlich in
realität gegossen werden können wenn
grüne politik realität wird dann
entstehen neue stadtviertel wie dieses
hier aus einer alten kaserne wurde ein
alternatives wohnprojekt gefördert von
der stadt ein quartier mit vielen
familien energiesparhäusern und
natürlich bio läden ein viertel
maßgeschneidert für grüne bedürfnisse
mit konservativen werten eine sehr
dörfliche eigentlich eine sehr dörfliche
struktur mit einer sehr städtischen
struktur so gut kombiniert also das
dörfliche ist eben dass man sich
eigentlich ja man kennt sich
untereinander die soziale kontrolle ist
auch relativ hoch also die kinder können
wirklich auch alleine einfach hier auf
der straße um flitzen und die treffen
überall an jeder ecke jemand man kennt
sich sehr stark merke ist dass hier
leute wohnen die hier absichtlich wohnen
also da hat man hier noch nichts geerbt
sondern mit hierher
viele junge leute sind schon ja
sicherlich auch viele gut gebildete
leute die auch vielleicht ein bisschen
alternativen lebensstil bevorzugen das
sammelt sich ja schon wenn man das wenn
man sich da wohl fühlt dann ist es
natürlich toll und für andere sind
gleich wieder nicht zu passen
es sind sehr bürgerliche träume vom
eigenen heim von sicherheit und
gemeinschaft in solchen projekten
realist
jetzt werden nur eben jetzt mit grünem
anstrich die baugruppe neckar blick will
im kommenden sommer einziehen
sie haben glück gehabt denn grundstück
in tübingen sind rar und sehr begehrt
jetzt entsteht hier ihr grünes heim das
sind extrem wärmegedämmte wohnungen wir
werden sehr wenig energie kosten haben
die stadtnähe ist für uns auch ganz
wichtig und integration auch von ganz
verschiedenen bevölkerungsgruppen das
letztlich auch was grünes für mich grüne
politik in tübingen
das zeigt sich schon auf der straße nur
wenige städte dieser größe in
deutschland setzen so auf den
öffentlichen nahverkehr wie tübingen
außerdem hat die stadt ihren co2 ausstoß
um zehn prozent gesenkt erfolge die den
grünen oberbürgermeister palmer hohe
zustimmung bringen und so kann palma
auch gelassen mit begriffen umgehen die
sonst bei den grünen eher abwehrreflex
hervorrufen volkspartei manche dieses
zeichen ich finde wir sind bereits
erfolgt partei wenn die frage lautet wie
entsprechen wir an wir sprechen das
ganze volk an wir sind keine partei mehr
die eine avantgarde oder eine
jugendbewegung adressiert palma steht
für bürgerliche grüne und wirbt für
bürgerliche koalition die cdu zum
beispiel müsse ein möglicher partner
sein
schließlich hätten die konservativen
viele grüne positionen übernommen
die cdu hat die barrieren zu den grünen
niedergerissen und dann weiß ich nicht
warum wir so tun soll als wäre das alles
nicht passiert denn das sind ja unsere
erfolge wir haben diese republik
verändert und zwar mehr als die republik
uns oder um im bild des obstbauern zu
bleiben
manche nast muss man abschneiden um
wachsen zu können
in alle richtungen